confidence is the present tense of Hope
it is not the path which is the
difficulty
rather
it is the difficulty which is the path
most people seek pleasure in ways they
will never find
listen to these Soren Kierkegaard quotes
and open your heart to the true joys of
the soul today
life can only be understood backwards
but it must be lived forwards
people demand freedom of speech as a
compensation for the freedom of thought
which they seldom use
anxiety is the dizziness of freedom
people understand me so poorly that they
don't even understand my complaint about
them not understanding me
life is not a problem to be solved
but a reality to be experienced
the most common form of despair
is not being Who You Are
the most painful state of being is
remembering the future
particularly the one you'll never have
what if everything in the world were a
misunderstanding
what if laughter were really tears
do it or don't do it
you will regret both
knowledge is a wealth that cannot be
stolen
[Music]
once you label me you negate me
to dare
to lose one's footing momentarily
not to dare is to lose oneself
there are two ways to be fooled
one is to believe what isn't true
the other is to refuse to believe what
is true
[Music]
the Tyrant dies and his rule is over
the Martyr dies and his rule begins
it is better to try something and fail
than to try nothing and succeed
the result may be the same but you won't
be
we always grow more through defeats than
victories
face the facts of being what you are
for that is what changes what you are
many of us pursue pleasure with such
breathless haste that we hurry past it
it is so hard to believe
because it is so hard to obey
the door to happiness opens outward
take a chance and you may lose
take not a chance
and you have lost already
boredom is the root of all evil
the despairing refusal to be oneself
it is impossible to exist without
passion
[Music]
for without risk there is no faith
and the greater the risk
the greater the faith
man always hopes for what he should
remember
and forever remembers what he should
hope for
the self-assured believer is a greater
sinner in the eyes of God
than the troubled disbeliever
leap of faith
yes but only after reflection
the thing that cowardice fears most
is decision
the unhappy person is never present to
themselves
because they always live in the past or
the future
wherever there is a crowd there is
untruth
why bother remembering a past that
cannot be made into a present
the question is not to be or not to be
it is what we should be until we are not
the truth is a trap
you cannot get it without it getting you
you cannot get the truth by capturing it
only by its capturing you
on the secretly blushing cheek
is reflected the glow of the heart
our life always expresses the result
of our dominant thoughts
happiness is the greatest hiding place
for despair
it is very important in life to know
when your cue comes
my sorrow is my castle
take away the Paradox from The Thinker
and you have a professor
a no does not hide anything
but a yes very easily becomes a
deception
in order to help another effectively you
must understand what he understands
instruction begins when you put yourself
in his place so that you may understand
what he understands and in the way he
understands it
once you are born in this world
you're old enough to die
hope is a passion for the possible
cultivate the will
this is the armor that preserves the
mind
the function of prayer is not to
influence God
but rather to change the nature of the
one who prays
therefore do not deceive yourself
of all deceivers fear most yourself
the more people who believe something
the more apt it is to be wrong
the person who's right often has to
stand alone
if you want to be loathsome to God
just run with the herd
only the noble of heart are called to
difficulty
my standpoint is armed neutrality
the only intelligent tactical response
to Life's horror
is to laugh defiantly at it
to be lost in spiritlessness
is the most terrible thing of all
what is youth
a dream
What is love
the dream's content
we were given the Commandment
love your neighbor as yourself
but if this commandment is correctly
understood
then you can read in it the opposite
statement
you must love yourself properly
we pretend to be unable to understand
life
because we know very well that the
minute we understand
we are obliged to act accordingly
Whoever has learned to be anxious in the
right way
has learned the ultimate
most people are subjective toward
themselves and objective toward all
others
frightfully objective sometimes but the
task is precisely to be objective toward
oneself
and subjective toward all others
it is better to get lost in the passion
than to lose the passion
the highest and most beautiful things in
life are not to be heard about
nor read about
nor seen But if one will
are to be lived
I would rather be a swine herd
understood by the swine
then a poet misunderstood by men
life has its own hidden forces which you
can only discover by living
truth always rests with the minority
and the minority is always stronger than
the majority
because the minority is generally formed
by those who really have an opinion
while the strength of a majority is
illusory
far from the idleness being the root of
all evil
it is rather the only true good
people settle for a level of Despair
they can tolerate and call it happiness
[Music]
to be a woman is something so strange so
confusing and so complicated
that only a woman could put up with it
sleeping is the height of Genius
our life is a game of whose rules we
don't know
for it is not what happens to me that
makes me great
but it is what I do
[Music]
faith is the highest passion in a man
you become what you understand
life has become a bitter drink to me
and yet it must be taken in drops
counted one by one
be that self that one is
Faith begins precisely where thinking
leaves off
I opened my eyes and saw the real world
and I began to laugh
and I haven't stopped since
learn not to tell anything to anyone
because only then your life will
definitely get better
what distinguishes all love from lust is
the fact that it Bears an impression of
Eternity
the best response to criticism
is to smile and forget
the highest after all is not to
comprehend the highest
but to do it
if you don't have many friends
that means you have a lot of life
experience
nothing ventured nothing gained
the more silent you are the more you are
able to hear
to be human is not a fact
but a task
these quotes from sorenkirkgaard not
only show his critical thinking
but also gives us a way to understand
this philosophical genius
thank you for watching